- Good afternoon.
Thank you all for joining
us for this exciting event.
I'm glad to finally
have an audience at YQI
and you also have some
people joining us online
and we cannot wait to
welcome actual visitor
on campus very soon.
My name is Florian Carle.
I'm the manager of the
Yale Quantum Institute
and the curator of the series
of non-technical talks,
co-sponsored by their friends at
the Franke Program for
Science and the Humanities.
The goal of these events
is to combat science phobia
and to bring a new
regard to quantum physics
and science in general,
by having experts, casts new lights on
often overlooked aspect
of the scientific work.
(indistinct) studying in
the spring semester of 2017
And we discussed a variety of topics,
among them, the introduction
of music and quantum physics,
art and science, physics and dance,
board games and space exploration,
mathematic and crochet
and so on and so on.
This evening we have
the pleasure to welcome
the multimedia video
artist, composer and writer,
Paul Miller also known as DJ Spooky.
His work immerse audiences
in a blend of genres,
global culture,
environmental social issues,
and Paul Miller has collaborated
with an array of recording artists,
including Metallica, Chuck
D, Steve Reich and Yoko Ono.
But also with renowned
physicists like Brian Greene,
Marcelo Gleiser, Stephon
Alexander and Janna Levin.
He's large-scale multimedia
performance pieces
including "Rebirth of a
Nation," "Terra Nova,"
that was commissioned by the
Brooklyn Academy of Music,
and the "Seoul
Counterpoints" that he wrote
during his 2014 residency at
Seoul Institute of the Arts,
and his big multimedia project,
"Quantopia: The Evolution
of the Internet,"
that he will talk a little
bit later on during the serc,
was commissioned by San
Francisco's Archive,
the Internet Archive in 2019.
We welcome Paul Miller in September,
as a third artist in residence
at the Yale Quantum Institute.
In this role, Paul Miller will interact
with the faculty members,
researchers and students,
attend our events and colloquia,
and produce data-driven
multimedia immersive artwork
which is based on the
work of researcher at YQI
and their collaboration.
If you're interested
in meeting Paul Miller,
with him and work with him,
please reach out to me and
I'll arrange a meeting for you.
Tonight, Paul will represent
informal history of invisible things.
The talk will last about
45 minutes to 50 minutes,
and then we have time for questions.
And if you are online,
please use the Q&A
feature to ask a question.
Please help me welcome
Paul Miller. Thank you.
- First and foremost, I just want to say,
thanks so much to everyone for joining me.
And I know it's a
gorgeous weather outside,
so it's a real treat
to be with human beings
and you forget that the pandemic,
it's been a very long 18 months, right?
I mean, people in a room,
who would have guessed?
So what I want to do today
is unpack a couple issues
that will give you guys a
little bit of a foundation
to some of the work I'll be looking at,
over the next several months,
but also give you a bit of
context to why the relationship
between Yale Quantum
Institute and me as an artist,
relates to the kind of the
legacy of what I think of
as interdisciplinary approach
to the sciences and the arts,
and, above all, creating
a more robust conversation
between science and art
and of course, the role of the composer
and artist in the 21st century.
I have a tendency to be very nonlinear,
so I'm not going to give you guys
a normal straight ahead PowerPoint.
That's just the way it is.
All right, we begin with a simple image.
I wanted to begin with this idea
of pattern recognition in nature.
This is broccoli and amusingly enough,
if you start to think about nature,
biomimicry and mathematics,
there's always a relationship between
how we look at pattern recognition
and how pattern recognition
actually informs
almost all aspects of human cognition
and how we put together
the fragments of meaning
that make up our,
for lack of a word, I'm just
gonna make up a pun here,
cognitive bandwidth.
And how much we process
the information around us
is based on, one could argue,
whether you're David Hume
or for that matter Rousseau,
or fast forward to other philosophers
like Deleuze Temari or
Jacques Derrida, you name it.
The whole pun here is
that pattern recognition
is how human beings navigate
the very complex world around us
and how it gives us grounding.
In a world, that one could argue,
is filled with uncertainties,
even about the basic humanity
and the way that we relate to
this complex universe around us.
So if we jump from broccoli to fractals,
this is a Mandelbrot set,
you can easily see that there's a kind of
a compelling relationship
between mathematics and nature
and, above all, nature
as the human evolves
over the last several
hundred thousand years,
we can easily see that we've been
in this process of trying to,
there's a very wonderful Israeli
philosopher, Yuval Harari.
If you haven't read
"Sapiens," it's a great book.
Human beings have been
involved with this notion of
sort of suppressing aspects of nature
as we move further into the 21st century
and the industrial revolution gave way to,
one could argue, an
information revolution.
And now as we move further
into a data-driven society,
we'll be seeing far more engagements
with disruption of nature
and of course that's
where environmentalist
call now the Anthropocene era.
So math, nature and, above
all, pattern recognition.
These are things that are compelling,
but also deeply disturbed.
The psychologist Sigmund Freud
would call this the
uncanny, the unheimlich,
it's a German term for meaning unholy
or at the edge of the familiar.
For many in the audience, this
is a simple kind of graph,
diagram of a mathematical process.
But if you bounce it off of nature
and you see the same thing
and how this vegetable, for example,
was just optimizing its
relationship to sunlight,
to be able to optimize its
relationship to resources
and, above all, create, one
could argue, a tasty meal.
It means that nature and humans,
we are not separate and, above all,
the 19th century, one could argue,
took us down a strange
path of industrialization
and the idea of scarcity
and, above all, this notion
that capitalism had set up
this notion of a deterministic universe.
Which leads me to this gentleman.
This is Simon Pierre Laplace.
He is a gentlemen who felt
that at the beginning of,
maybe the middle of the 18th century.
I say the beginning, maybe
the late 18th century.
There was, above all, a
relationship to revolution.
One could argue the
French and the Americans
and many of the other global cultures
were involved with a series of upheavals
that many environmentalists have traced
to what they call the short ice age.
There was a tremendous
amount of crop failure
in the mid-18th century,
because a volcanic eruption had sent
a tremendous amount of
particles into the atmosphere.
And so winters were colder and longer
and summers were kind of faint.
And so there's a lot of people who feel
that the 18th century upheavals,
including the revolutions,
can be tied directly to climate change.
But he wrote an essay that's gonna inform
some of the discussions today.
The English translation
is just simply called
"A Philosophical Essay on Probabilities."
And he felt that you could actually,
if you had enough computational power,
that you would be able
to predict the movement
of every particle making
up the entire universe.
Now here in the 21st century
our notion of computational realism,
of being able to actually
have the computational power
to be able to engage
this kind of thinking,
it's a pretty powerful moment.
And one can argue that the 18th
century deterministic model,
whether it's Newtonian,
classical, physics,
or whether, later on,
one could argue that this
kind of deterministic thinking
set the tone for the 20th century's idea
of the industrial psychology
that led to all other
elements being disrupted.
When I say all the other
elements, for example,
humans and nature,
the idea of the human
place as we move further
into the Anthropocene
and, above all, the idea that patterns
were rigidly controlled and deterministic.
The idea of freewill, for
example, and Facebook,
freewill and Facebook.
And obviously there's a
huge scandal right now,
but if you look at Cambridge Analytica
and many of the other data mining
and data surveillance industries,
they're based on this idea
that it's relatively trivial
to compute how human beings engage
with the information around them
and the patterns around them.
And thus things like
Instagram, Facebook, TikTok,
these are all computational machineries
that are engaged with manipulation
and, above all, sort of
colonizing the subconscious
as it goes further into
a data-driven narrative.
So Pierre-Simon Laplace,
I'll just read this out loud,
just so everyone can be
on the same page here,
it says, "We may regard the present state
of the universe as the effect of its past
and the cause of its future.
An intellect, which at a certain moment,
would know all forces
that set nature in motion
and all positions of all items
of which nature is composed,
if this intellect were also vast enough
to submit these data to analysis,
it would embrace in a single formula
the movements of the greatest
bodies of the universe.
and those are the tiniest atom,
for such an intellect
nothing would be uncertain
and the future just like the past
would be present before its eyes."
Now, whether you're an Aristotelian
or someone who believes
in the platonic ideals of,
the foundations of Western philosophy,
this still relates to how
we think about structure
and its relationship to how a determinist
versus indeterminist, a sort
of cognitive process works.
Other philosophers like
Rousseau, for example,
we call this, the unmoved mover.
A Daemon, a demon, D-A-E-M-O-N,
that would imaginarily create a structure
where you'd have to always be guessing,
but guess what?
You could fast forward to Schrodinger
and other kinds of physicists
who are still influenced by this
and Schrodinger's infamous cat,
where you're able to think about
the idea of randomness
and chance operations,
all of this still lingers
over the conversation.
From these 18th century philosophers,
Rousseau, Laplace and so on,
you can easily see that
there was a deep tension
in philosophy and science
and of course, Newton navigated that
and led the path for people like Einstein.
Let's give you guys a
little bit of context.
I'm an artist, a writer, a musician
who's deeply enmeshed in thinking
about the conversation
between science and the arts.
My father was Dean of Howard
University's Law School.
I grew up in Washington,
DC in the ancient 1970s.
So I'll just show you guys quick,
this is Dupont Circle in
Washington, DC in the early '70s.
My mother was a historian of design
and my father was Dean of
Howard University's Law School.
There was a tremendous amount
of political activity at that time,
you had J. Edgar Hoover, you had Nixon,
Vietnam War is raging.
Some of the cases my father
represented, for example,
he was a lawyer for Angela Davis
and the Black Panthers, very political.
So our household was near Dupont Circle.
I don't know if anybody here knows DC,
but growing up in that region, there was,
you had the embassies,
you had a very international
cosmopolitan scene.
I had friends from China,
Russia, India, Japan.
So growing up in a downtown
Washington DC context,
we also had, there was a
vegetarian punk scene, for example.
I don't know if you guys
know bands like Fugazi,
which was, or Minor Threat, or Bad Brains.
Anyone who's into thrash punk.
I don't know, you guys
might not be into them,
but it was popular at the time.
So growing up in a cosmopolitan situation
made me realize that
the idea that science,
the arts and history,
were all kind of in this
American uneasiness.
And as we've seen during the pandemic,
we're not just facing
a biological pandemic,
we're facing an ideological
and political crisis
based on the crisis of democracy
as it collides with the social media
and Facebook and Twitter
and Instagram itself.
So going back to that time period,
the legacies I'm inherited
are from that kind of era.
Critique of the political discourse,
thinking about human rights,
thinking about history,
and this disruptive
innovation that was going on
as the world became more and more digital.
So fast forward to our current moment,
this is some of my artwork.
This is a fun remix of Lewis Carroll.
I tend to always
incorporate found materials.
This is some of my visual artwork.
I'm a big fan of Lewis Carroll
and obviously he was
someone who would play
with the mythology of mathematics
and many of his works,
of course "Alice in
Wonderland" are foundational
to, one could argue, this sort
of computational narratives
that we inhabit now.
In fact, the science fiction
writer, Neal Stephenson,
if you haven't read his work,
he's a wonderful writer,
his book, "Snow Crash," for example.
He coined the term, the metaverse,
which we haven't encountered.
It's well worth exploring.
So when you start to think
about the visual arts,
many of my other friends
in this kind of context
are artists such as Shep Fairey.
Shep, for example, made
the Obama "Hope" poster,
which became very popular
when Obama was running.
There's also, all sorts of
other artists who I think...
Shep does "Obey."
He went to RISD and I went to
Bowdoin College up in Maine.
So just giving you guys
a little bit of context,
if you haven't seen his work,
you probably seen the stickers that say,
"Andre the giant has a posse."
We've known each other
since we were in college,
I went to Bowdoin and
RISD had better parties,
so we would drive down
there on the weekends.
All right, you have a
little bit of context.
And now, how does this relate to science?
Let's give you guys a little
bit of a interpretation.
There's a very dear friend of
mine named Margaret Atwood.
If you haven't read her work,
currently, the world is
feeling like one of her books,
actually, "The Handmaid's Tale."
Margaret is a science fiction writer
who uses feminist narratives to critique
how we think about the near future
and control of women's bodies.
"The Handmaiden's Tale" is a
absolute classic hands-down,
if you haven't read it,
but she inspires a lot
of my thinking right now
about the legacy of the body
as it orientates in this world of,
how should I put this,
of coercive technologies.
Some of my other work is presented
in the context of
installations at museums,
galleries and things like that.
One of my favorite concerts,
and again I'm just using
this as an example,
was we got the Greek government to give me
the Acropolis for an evening
and I projected, throughout
the ruins of the Acropolis,
a very infamous film by D.W. Griffith,
called "Birth of a Nation."
And for those who are into film history,
the film is deeply controversial,
but it's considered the DNA of Hollywood.
Basically, it's a film that shows,
it's a KKK propaganda film.
Just for the record, just to clarify,
just to tell you guys as an audience,
I can assure you I'm not a KKK member.
(woman laughing)
But basically when I was in negotiations
with the Greek government, they were like,
"But why do you want to play
a KKK film at the Acropolis?"
and I was like, "That's a good question."
So I was like, "Look, you guys are Greek.
You have comedy, tragedy."
and they're like, "Ah, I get it, okay."
So what they did was
they allowed me to put
a sound system throughout the ruins
and what we ended up doing was projecting
different versions of the
film throughout the ruins.
So the audience would come into,
this is called the
Herodes Atticus theater,
it's the beginning of modern theater,
if you think about it.
This kind of semi-circle,
you can still see that as a logo
for our modern movie
theaters, for example.
You might be thinking,
"What does this have to do with science?"
I'm building up to that.
But when you start to think about,
these kind of temple of reason,
Athena and Heracles,
and the idea that at that time
democracy was very fragile
and the competition between
Sparta and Athens had generated
this intense, for lack of a better word,
critique of the individual and the state.
So later on the Romans came in
and obviously they took over,
but this theater became the basic premise
of how rhetoric and how exchange of ideas,
if you could look on further, of course,
people like Aristotle, Plato,
they would be hanging out in this area
and there was an area called
the Agora, the public space.
So somebody would jump
up on a stone and say,
"This is my philosophy."
And then somebody else down
the road would be saying,
"Hey, this is my philosophy," and so on.
So what lingers over the
conversation today is Pythagoras.
I'm a huge fan of him.
He was also a controversial figure.
And for those who are into
the history of mathematics,
he's generally considered to be
one of the first ancient
philosophers to be able
to combine tuning systems and math.
The thing about Greeks culture's
that they didn't have zero
and zero obviously is incredibly important
in the evolution of how
we think about the arts,
how we think about tuning systems
and how we think about
our modern binary code
that drives every digital
device around you,
zeroes and ones.
Pythagoras was a deeply troubled
person, one could argue.
He had a cult of
mathematicians around him.
You were not allowed to see his face.
He would speak through a veil
and he would only speak
to you in equations.
If you were not able to
answer the equations,
you were not worth speaking to.
His most feared thing was the
square root of negative one.
As a matter of fact, there's rumors that
he would have you assassinated
if you spoke a square root
of negative one aloud,
because he felt that it
would unravel the universe.
But what inspired Pythagoras
as an ancient Greek philosopher
was this tension between
the public space and math.
And if you look at, I'll
give you another example,
the Oracle of Delphi for example,
all of this goes to the
heart of Western mathematics
as tied into the social
process, nothing was separate.
As one could argue, that
interdisciplinary foundation
of Western math, inspired architecture,
inspired philosophy, inspired
pretty much everything
that currently drives our society.
I'm giving you a little
bit of context on this
as a way of showing how art
can intervene in architecture.
Art can also intervene
in the social process
and, above all, how we think
about contemporary practice
as an interdisciplinary space.
There's plenty of other art projects,
but I want to give you guys
a little bit of context as
well, just for that arc.
This is a very famous situation from 1915,
it's the Italian Futurists.
The gentleman on the
left with the mustache,
his name's Luigi Russolo
and basically at this time,
he came up with this series
of projects called "Futurism."
And basically, the Futurist movement
wanted to do invisible portraits
of a accelerated landscape
and he felt that the
science of the imagination,
literally we call it the
was gonna be about the tension of how
a culture was accelerating
because of industrialization
and he would have these Futurist concerts.
In 1915 the audience
would walk into your room,
much like this and the
concert would be coming
out of these crazy speakers.
And so the audience would riot,
people would throw bottles at him,
they were booing and they
would say, "Where's the band?"
People were very upset that the music
was coming out of these speakers
and he was like, "The music of the future
will all be coming out of this."
And if you can look above you
and see all those speakers,
you can see who won.
From 1915 to our time period,
you can usually see that the arts
have had a nonlinear relationship,
both with the industrial process,
with how people think
of the creative economy
and, above all, how science informs
the practice of this notion
of collapsing the silos between mediums.
Another project that I just
want to bring to your attention,
I went to Antarctica for six
weeks, a little while ago,
and there was a group of scientists
working on a project called "Ice Cube."
Antarctica has some of the
best landscapes in the world
for studying the interaction of neutrinos.
And what's beautiful about this project,
was I got a chance to really go deep
into these larger landscapes of ice.
And so when I was there,
I was doing what I call
acoustic portraits of ice
and ice is a stunningly
beautiful material.
It's quite, I'll show you in a moment,
it's quite mathematical.
But you can easily see this
is a landscape of devastation.
The landscape is collapsing
and you can easily see in the collapse,
it's scraping the entire side
of a mountain, for example.
Now, most of North America was carved
by the retreat of the glaciers
in the last several thousand years
and one could argue that
we're in an accelerated,
again, Anthropocene era
where nature and disruption of, obviously,
this summer was the wildest
summer in human history,
forest fires, crazy weather patterns.
So buckle up, it's gonna get a lot deeper.
And going to Antarctica
from the heart of New York
and then doing, what I call,
these acoustic portraits
was a real eye-opener about
the legacy of deep time.
What you're seeing here is
tens of millions of years
vanishing in the space
of a couple of decades.
And so we're looking at a collision
of human time and deep time.
And so as a composer,
how do you engage that?
How do you think about this
notion of pattern recognition
lingering over an entire
rise of a species,
our species, in such a
short amount of time.
So we're seeing the acceleration
and disruption of the entire biome
and, above all, we're also seeing
that the human sense of agency
has now created a way of
thinking about our imagination
as applied to the entire
universe around us.
And one could argue, Laplace, Rousseau,
maybe they weren't so far off.
Maybe we are imagining it all
and our intervention in
this is quite intriguing.
Most of my books are
published with MIT Press
and I've been working
with MIT for many years.
The current book that I'm working on now
is called, "Digital Fictions."
I just wanna show you this really quickly.
This is a map, it's a
little blurry for you,
I'll just zoom in really quickly.
It's called the acoustic wave spectrum
and I used this in my last book
because I wanted to show people
a macro versus micro level wave forms.
Imagine a wave form that can,
I'll just zoom in, so
hopefully you can see this,
a wave form that would
last over a million years.
So you're looking at oceanic cycles,
you're looking at tectonic plate movement.
You're looking at, I'll
just zoom out here,
biospheric cycles.
And then maybe we'll go down in the scale,
for millions of years,
to maybe a pattern that might
last over several months,
global wave, seasonal cycles and so on.
Planetary cycles rotation of, you know,
different phenomenon and atmosphere.
Then we zoom down to the frequency
in cycles to the human range,
which is usually, our
hearing is between one
and 100,000 cycles per second.
We hear and can interact with
these kinds of wave forms,
mechanical oscillation, surface waves,
what they call capitation, conical waves,
sound waves that obviously,
a truck going by or whatever.
And then if we go below the human range
down to a micro acoustic level, you know,
millions of cycles per second,
hundreds of thousands
of cycles per second,
you can easily start to
see that it starts getting
into the realm of quantum
mechanics and other forms of,
thinking about these micro,
micro, micro, micro levels
and the wave forms then become far more,
what you call electroacoustic,
magnetoacoustic, photonic and so on.
And the human ear, obviously,
is not evolved to engage this mechanism,
but technology, given our current process,
we've been able to engage
these kinds of wave forms
and being able to then use them
for all sorts of different approaches.
Every device you have in your pocket,
your cell phone, lights,
all of this comes out of
the engagement between,
obviously, the last century's
notions of quantum mechanics
and then updated through the filter
of what became a consumer
culture based on that.
These wave forms are all
part of everyday life,
but at the same time, there's
a deep physics approach
to how the human ear helps us
navigate the world around us.
Each of those is different
kinds of processes
and I want to make sure
that as an audience,
you realize that this is information
that can lead you down many paths
and I celebrate that.
There's one of my favorite composers,
also a Greek composer,
his name is Iannis Xenakis
and he began a kind of approach
where he incorporated algorithms
and he called this style of composition,
the stochastic method.
Here we are at Yale Quantum Institute
and stochastic processes,
obviously entropy and
other kinds of things.
Those are, again, part of this
notion of quantum engagement
and how do we think about that?
But he would take ancient
Greek mathematic formulas
and turn them into symphonies.
Me and him did a series of collaborations.
And this is the beginning of my career,
I had, obviously, a lot
more hair back then.
But the fun part about
the way the ancient Greeks
would think about math in the everyday
was that it was part of
this emotional engagement
with how you thought about intervening
and pattern recognition.
He's one of my favorite composers
and his work influences my thinking a lot.
Again, he's one of the first composers
to use algorithms to generate symphonies.
Let's go to a little
bit more current stuff.
One project I'm working on now,
is what you call
computational neuroscience.
And what I've been doing is
working on brainwave patterns.
The human mind generates generally
five wave form frequencies
that are easy to quantify and measure.
Delta, theta, alpha, beta, gamma.
So obviously each of those
is a frequency wave form
that the human ear doesn't pick up,
but your brain is generating it.
And what I've been doing over the summer
is working on mapping
out brain wave patterns
and then using those to generate sound
and then being able to balance meditation
or other approaches to thinking
about the brain and wave forms.
This is a rough draft
and this is just an acoustic portrait
of me thinking about some hip-hop.
So at the moment, this is a rough draft,
it'll get more intense, probably 2022.
But I'm giving you guys little projects
that can hopefully give
you a bit of context
about why I'm here with
the Yale Quantum Institute.
All right, so that's one project.
And then I did want to make sure
that you guys can also think about,
a little bit of the history
of what inspires my work.
I collect vinyl,
this is a very famous collaboration
between two of my favorite composers,
Sun Ra and John Cage.
John Cage most famously created a piece
called, "Four minutes, 30 seconds."
Or is it "Four minutes, 33 seconds?"
It's a famous piece
about silence, basically.
And Sun Ra is a legendary
figure who opened up
the idea of noise and free jazz.
The reason I think these two and physics,
is both of them were inspired
by interstellar phenomena
and the idea of silence.
This is very rare record.
I've been collecting
vinyls since I was a kid
and for me, at least half of this stuff
is always about the notion of the archive,
how you engage your archive,
how you reactivate your archive
and then how that becomes
a collage process.
These are all just bits and pieces.
And by the way, I could easily
put this in a slide format,
but I'm sick of PowerPoint,
so I like the idea of kind
of a non-linear scroll here.
Over the last couple of months,
I've been finishing a series of books
and some of my favorite authors,
this is a gentleman by the
name of William Gibson.
If you're not familiar with his work,
he coined the term
cyberspace, for example,
and his most famous book
is called "Neuromancer."
I'm very intrigued by the
science fictional relationship,
right now moving further
into a data-driven society
and there's, say for example,
there's a Chinese author
who's a big influence
on my work right now, Cixin Liu.
He wrote this book,
"The Three-Body Problem"
or "The Dark Forest" trilogy.
Gibson in the idea of cyberspace.
Again, Neal Stephenson is
another science fiction writer
who influences my thinking
with his term, the metaverse.
All of which means that the
science fictional relationship
to the world around us.
Other authors like Isaac
Asimov's or Philip K. Dick
also inform and inspire some of my work.
Let's see, I wanna make sure
that you guys are getting
a little bit of a broad spectrum.
I've been also doing some volunteer work
with reef restorations,
because I'm fascinated
with how ocean currents
and heat and temperature differentials
can actually generate this idea,
again, of living through
pattern recognition,
but also thinking about,
if the Anthropocene and radical disruption
of how nature is being wiped out by human,
just human location or pacing.
I do scuba diving and this is
a series of fun initiatives
where we're dealing with
putting reefs back together.
There's an island called Bonaire
that I go to occasionally
and I also go to Vanuatu and
Solomon Islands, Tahiti, Fiji,
and what we do is look at
different reef destruction
and then try and reboot
them with either grafts,
where you can have different reefs
from different regions of the world
and help them heal.
It's fun, it's interesting,
but you can easily see
there's a mathematical
relationship going on here
and the way that the coral
reefs are trying to optimize
their relationship to the ocean
currents and the salinity,
the temperature
differentials, the sunlight.
Regretfully, the planet
is on fire right now
and in the climate crisis is,
that's a whole different topic.
But I'm heavily involved with a lot
of climate active justice issues.
This is one of my favorite
projects at the moment
and actually we're gonna be,
hopefully, going back there,
or I will be going back later this year
to do a series of sculptural projects
and looking at how to sculpt the coral
so that it can both be
visually compelling,
but also help it grow
in a more robust way.
And again, these are radically
different projects I'm showing you guys
and I'm giving you guys
the cliff-notes version
just 'cause of time.
Okay. Let's see really quick.
I'm trying as much as possible
to give you guys a sensibility,
both how I do research,
but also how that research
then informs my process.
This is a gentleman who is
also a big inspiration to me,
his name is Al-Khawarizmi and
if you don't know his work,
he was in the eighth and ninth century
in Baghdad at the House of Wisdom
and he coined the term, algorithm,
which most Westerners do not
know, it's an Arabic term.
And the Arabs had borrowed these numbers,
including zero from the Hindu
and their notion of Sanskrit mathematics.
So his term basically,
became the foundation of Western math
because of Fibonacci.
And Musa Al-Khawarizmi,
generally is considered to be,
the other derivative of
his name is Al-Devore.
So one could argue that the
conversation between east, west,
between Islam and science
and the way Muslim culture
actually helped preserve
a lot of records that the
ancient Greeks and Romans had,
they had taken one path in mathematics,
but had not had zero, for example.
Which leads me to a conversation
that inspires pretty much
this entire residency
and I wanna make sure foreground this.
2019 was the 50th
anniversary of the internet
and I was commissioned to do a symphony
celebrating this 50th anniversary.
So from 1969 to 2019, the
internet basically reached out
and changed the way we think
about pretty much everything.
This is the internet in
1969, there was four hubs.
The first two hubs went
live in October, 1969.
And again, you guys are based in physics
so we can easily see a
exponential notion of growth.
From October to December,
the first two hubs where between UCLA
and Stanford Research Institute,
you can see those two,
and then by December you have four,
then keep going, keep going, keep going.
Next thing you know, you have billions
and billions and billions of nodes.
But if you were a composer looking at
that notion of exponential growth,
how would you turn that
into a composition?
I was commissioned by
the Internet Archive,
which is a very incredible organization
out of San Francisco, UCLA,
and the San Francisco Young Women's Choir.
I reached out to the gentleman
who wrote this equation,
and I just want to make
sure you're aware of this,
generally this is the equation that set up
what you call packet switching,
which allows the entire internet to work.
And the idea was the US
Military, through ARPANET,
needed a network to be
able to send messages
in case there was a nuclear war
or if there was other disruption
of major communication systems.
So he figured out a clever
way to break a message
into component elements
based on zeroes and ones.
And essentially what I ended
up doing was working with him.
Dr. Leonard Kleinrock, if you look him up,
he's generally considered to be
one of the founders of the internet.
End up working with him to do a research
into how we think about
message component systems
and I then took that and made it become,
so this is me and Dr. Leonard Kleinrock,
and I took his equations
and then had a chorus,
the San Francisco Young
Women's Choir sing it.
And I'll just show you
what that would look like.
Each young woman is singing
parts of the equation
and then I had a string
quartet that I'm sampling,
running through my software.
And this was presented at UCLA.
And eventually what happens is you have
more and more and more nodes.
And the women are all wearing black
and we're projecting on them
and I'd taken the equation
and then run it through
a alogarithmic series of growth patterns.
So you can usually see its relationship
to the exponential growth of the internet.
So you're hearing all
these young women's voices,
sort of cascading around the room
and then sampling the string quartet
through various software that I use.
So this is just one project.
But this is called "Quantopia,"
which simply stands for Quantified Utopia.
Each of the projects
I'm presenting to you,
you're getting a three
to five minute version,
but generally that take
months of research,
you have to work with
people who commissioned it
and you have to work with,
it's not every day you can be a composer
and walk in and talk
to the Greek government
and get the Acropolis, I'm just saying.
So each of these takes
a tremendous amount of research and work
and it then becomes a
concert, or an installation,
or a series of conversations
with data scientists or other artists.
The reason I want to show you guys,
these are all totally different projects,
is that there has to be a
conversation across silos
and what the problem with
early 21st century is,
many of us are in our own silo.
As a matter of fact,
if you're a Facebook
group or this or that,
mathematically speaking,
you're just in what,
there's a theoretician named Eli Pariser,
who call the filter bubble.
You just keep getting the same thing,
because you're in your silo.
I want to break down those silos
and I'd like to communicate
across mediums and across disciplines.
So that's what this residency is about
and I'll be working with
the Yale Quantum Institute
over the next several months
and working with scientists
and other people from your community
to figure out a compelling way
to compose and generate art
based on this idea of
breaking down those silos.
One of the inspirations for the residency
is a conversation between
these two gentlemen.
On the right you have Rabindranath Tagore,
who is a Bengali Hindu poet
and on the left was Einstein.
These guys met backstage
at the Nobel Prize Awards
and stayed in touch.
They had the coolest haircuts in the room.
(woman laughing)
And what ended up
happening is they just got
into a series of debates and discussions
and Einstein said to
Rabindranath Tagore famously,
"When I'm working on an equation
and I can't finish the
equation, I go play violin."
And people tend to forget Einstein
was quite a talented violinist.
Some of his favorite
compositions are stuff
like Bach's "Mass in B Minor"
or Bach's "Goldberg Variations,"
which are quite mathematical.
And so the Rabindranath Tagore said,
"The problem with your Western music is,
you guys didn't have zero
and your music's too simple,
and you guys are all playing
minor chord or major chord."
And if you listen to Indian music,
you can easily hear this
rich complexity of tonality
because they incorporated
mathematics into the music
at a much earlier phase in their culture.
The West was still based
on the Greek model,
again, Pythagoras, Heraclides
and you can easily hear that whole tone.
Whenever you hear hip-hop,
techno, rock, jazz,
any of our current music,
it's still based a mainly
those Greek tuning systems.
Minor chord, major chord.
If anyone wants to get more technical,
it's like Lydian, Phrygian, Aeolian.
Those are all ancient Greek tribes
that just played specific style of music.
And again, I don't want
to lose half the audience
by getting in more technical with music.
But long story short, these
guys began a correspondence
and their correspondence was
about physics and poetry.
And it ended up becoming a book called,
"On the Nature of Reality."
It's a great book where you have
one of the world's leading poets
talking to one of the
world's leading physicists
and the conversation between
that creative ebb and flow
is what inspires me for this residency.
I'm a big fan of this idea of people
reaching across different
cultural boundaries
and across different silos
and how the 21st century is moving
is that everyone is being
put in a data bubble
based on your algorithmic preferences
and the coercion and surveillance
of all of these different
social media platforms.
So it's time to be human again maybe
and just be in a room with people.
And I guess still the pandemic,
and by the way, I'm fully vaccinated,
but I'm a big fan of thinking about
how do we break down these kinds of issues
and use them as building blocks
for conversation across the mediums.
So given our timeframe, it's 5:42.
I know that time is tight,
so I'm gonna just kinda
go to this one quote
that I really enjoyed,
using from Einstein, where he says,
"Imagination is more
important than knowledge.
Knowledge is limited.
Imagination encircles the world."
To me, at least, the imagination
is the ultimate renewable resource.
We have to think about resilience.
We have to think about sustainability
and we have to think
about the climate crisis
as basically having to
incentivize us to rethink
our relationship to the patterns
that we've constructed
in the world around us.
And that's where quantum physics
and, above all, thinking
about quantum computing
will hopefully allow us to
have a better and more robust,
and for what, one could argue,
a more powerful conversation
with how to restore some of the patterns
that we've disrupted.
If we unpack this phrase from
the viewpoint of the arts
and thinking about algorithmic processes
and mathematics and quantum mechanics,
the idea of being able
to imagine something
that you're unfamiliar with,
implies that you have to explore nuance.
And you have to be able to,
if there's a word that you haven't used
and you've never heard of,
will you have that vocabulary?
If there's an equation or an approach
to something that you've never engaged,
would you be able to think about it?
And one could argue philosophically
that you might not have
the cognitive processes
or structures because you've
never heard that before,
you've never thought of that before.
The idea for the residency
is to be a provocation
and to apply the logic of the DJ,
which is about remixing,
sampling, collage, the mashup,
to this notion of how science and the arts
can have a better and
more robust conversation.
And to me, at least, that's a beginning.
We're gonna see the evolution of that
over the next year and eventually,
I just want to show you, when
I got back from Antarctica,
I just wanna show you really quick.
I went from this, which is
one of the most remote places
on earth and seeing this massive,
it looked like a nuclear bomb
had gone off in the whole continent.
It's melting, I mean
let's just be clear here.
You can easily see the ice is collapsing.
The human scale of this
is so mind boggling.
And so once you think about
the idea of scalability of experience,
patterns are what allow us to
navigate these kind of issues.
When I got back, we had a concert,
where me and a group of other artists
did a series of music pieces
and each of us did a different style.
I've worked with the
hip hop group The Roots,
which I'm not sure if you
guys are familiar with,
and there also another group
called The Flaming Lips.
And each of us did a different approach.
So I did one style, they did one style
and I just want to show you the concert.
It's a lot of photos here,
I always forget which...
But essentially the concert
was one of the largest,
it was for Earth Day
and what we did was
try as much as possible
to engage the notion of
how people would think
about Earth Day and disruption
and giving people better
tools for critical thinking.
To me, at least, that's one of
the most powerful things we can have.
and it really gives us a
sensibility that the imagination,
like I was saying earlier,
is the ultimate renewable resource.
How do we get people to rethink
the process of re-imagining
what is possible?
For one reason or other,
I can't seem to find the concert photo,
but it was a big concert.
I don't know if you guys
know The Flaming Lips
or The Roots, it was a popular show.
One other thing, let's see,
trying to make sure to
give you guys some context.
This is what I do normally
like kids are rockin' out.
That's about 10,000 people
in front of the stage.
Amusing if all these girls
were throwing their bra on the stage,
I'm very un-PC to say that, but it's real.
So this is the view from the DJ booth.
I'm normally, playing beats and people
are rockin' and stuff like that.
So this is not what I'm
gonna be doing with Yale.
Although maybe we can
make some quantum hip-hop
and we'll figure,
but the fun part about this
is that it is a social process
and to be able to have fun
and also be able to get
the conversation moving
outside of the silos
and being able to break those silos down.
That's what's gonna be
the next several months
of what's going on.
The concert that we did for Earth Day
was something like that,
but all the music that I had made
was generated by the
recordings I made in Antarctica
and amusingly and strangely enough,
when you start to think about project,
the research that goes into the project
is what makes part of
it so intriguing to me.
So I'll be coming up here
over the next several months
and having a series of engagements
with scientists, with creatives
and, above all, with people.
I'm just trying to figure, where is that?
I have so many freaking photos.
There's various videos
I could show you guys,
there's various, oh here we go.
So for this one, we had
about a million plus people
and that's me DJing.
We filled the entire,
this is at the DC mall,
it's in a massive space.
So all the music I was playing
was generated in Antarctica
and I took the sound of ice.
I took the sound of the
temperature differentials
and then made electronic music out of it.
And then The Flaming Lips came out
and they did their part
of the concert where,
they're like an art rock band.
I'm more hip-hop.
Again, the idea was to
build bridges between styles
and then The Roots came out
and they're more straight
up normal hip-hop.
But I usually do
large-scale music festivals.
And the audience was into it
because the whole concert was based on
the sounds of nature that had been cut up,
sliced and diced into electronic music.
So you could party to the sound
of climate change and Anthropocene era.
(all chuckling)
The good news out of that is
that the audience was able
to relate to the fact that
you could actually make
an acoustic portrait of climate change
and that helped raise awareness.
And we also had a political engagement
with raising more awareness about
climate change and climate justice.
To me, that's a really
critical issue of our time
and it's gonna be, I would be surprised,
if our species makes it out
of this century, personally.
I know that sounds a little
cynical, but it's pretty bleak.
So there's plenty of other
stuff I could chat about.
I do want to leave time. It's 5:50.
- [Audience Member] Well, could
you give us a little sound
since you're keep showing us pictures?
You did sounds, are you
gonna give us a little sound?
- Sure, I mean, I was gonna play a mashup
just to give you a sense
of how I was scratching.
And also there's plenty
of video of me doing stuff
on the internet anyway.
By the way, I do want to,
and thank you for bringing it up
and I will play one thing in one moment,
but I do want to emphasize, I mean,
this is like, just going to...
It's not everyday you
have a DJ from New York
go to the middle of Antarctica.
- [Audience Member] I thought
you were going to say to you
that you hate it.
(audience laughing)
- You guys have quite a
few DJs coming through,
I'm pretty sure.
But the idea here is, think
about this as a pattern
that's in disruption.
You're seeing the collapse
of an entire glacial shelf.
As a matter of fact, a lot
of scientists are saying
that essentially this entire area
is now collapsing into the ocean.
When I was there, it took
about eight hours to walk
from that water all the way up
to the side of this mountain.
And I was very hot by
it, because you're moving
and by the time I got to
the top of the mountain,
I'd been wearing all this gear
and I was, "Oh my God, it's frying."
So each of these projects requires
a tremendous amount of editing,
recording, documentation,
but when I got back from going to this
and then had the concert for Earth Day,
the audience doesn't see all that.
They want a party or something
that's kind of immersive and fun.
For me, at least, this
idea of the research
is where I derive personal satisfaction.
Let me play you guys.
I mean, I have lots of albums out too,
but at the Antarctica project
is particularly resonant
with Yale right now,
because I think that
a lot of it's gonna be
about its conversations with scientists.
And by the way, Antarctica
is the only place on earth
with no government,
so I made the entire project open source.
And the idea is that you
can take the climate data
and make your own remixes.
All of this is available on my website,
if you go to www.DJspooky.com
and I'll just show you really quickly.
The idea was as much as
possible to reference...
Let's see.
Yeah. Okay.
So what I did was take those
temperature differentials.
This is temperature over several years.
This is you just seeing
a small sliver of it
and then take the
temperature differentials,
assign them to music tone patterns.
Then use those patterns to
generate, what you call,
an algorithmic musical transcription
of weather over a long period of time.
And then use that to generate music
based on these different
algorithmic transcription.
Again, I can get more
technical if everybody wants,
but basically it's patterns
that you can put into different tempos.
So house music, techno, dubstep, hip-hop,
they're all patterns.
So once you have the basic
pattern of the weather
and the temperature differentials,
I was able to take that and
make an open source album.
The album is on my website.
If you just go to
www.DJspooky.com/antarctica,
all of the data is there
and it was done with Darkness
Cold Regions Research Labs.
Each of these products,
I could do an entire talk
on just for that product,
but I do want to show you some of that.
We're lifting the hood
of the car a little bit.
So this is just a little backdrop.
Each of these products could be full on,
but I do want to just
show you really quickly.
The inspiration for that project
was this gentleman, Johannes Kepler.
And basically he was on his way home
in the middle of a snow storm
and he basically realized
that a piece of ice
had landed on his sleeve
and he wrote the first equations
defining the geometry of ice.
It's pretty wild.
This is in the year 1611
and he's on his way home in
the middle of a snow storm
and this, like a piece of
ice lands on his sleeve
and he realizes how geometric it is.
And basically ends up thinking
about the geometry of ice
as the foundations for this book,
"The Six Sides of a Snowflake."
It's the first time you have
a mathematical interpretation
of the geometry of ice
and you realize you can
see the geometry of ice
pretty clearly, pretty easily,
and what you're seeing is
permutations of the changing same.
This is literally the same,
if you took the same equation,
you will be able to
generate different things.
So I was like, "Oh,
let's take the equation."
So what I did was run it
through different patterns
and I took a capillary material,
used it to generate more and
more fractal relationships
and you realize after enough computation,
you can have synthetic ice.
And so basically each of these projects,
there's the science component
and then there's the fun component.
So I need to, as an artist,
I was trying to sort of balance the two,
because if you make it too much,
then you lose some of the audience.
And if you make it too little,
The good idea is to
just be able to balance.
For example, like I was
showing you earlier,
eventually, for example,
this is one of the installation pieces
we had at the Metropolitan Museum of Art.
And I took the geometry of the ice.
I worked with a group of architects
and we developed a series of sculptures
that we projected on.
That was like the art version.
And then that other one
where like a million plus
people for Earth Day,
that was the party version.
There's plenty of other
stuff I could show you guys,
but I just want to wrap up
because time, it's 5:55.
This is a very, I think,
inspirational piece from Richard Dawkins,
where he says science is
the poetry of reality.
I began my discussion by showing you guys
the conversation between
Einstein and Rabindranath Tagore.
And I'll end with Dawkins,
where this simple phrase is,
I think, an elegant distillation
of some of the ideas
that are gonna be inspiring the residency
over the next several months.
And so the idea is to work with you all,
work with the Institute
and see what we can do
from the conversation.
And again, to go back
to the ancient Greeks,
they would call this
a dialectical process.
You have thesis, antithesis and synthesis.
So the gentleman asked for some music.
I can play you,
there's different versions of everything
because that's what the
idea of DJ culture is,
it's remix and mashup.
So I just want to play you
one that I find amusing,
but it's not definitive of my style.
A lot of people, like
if you hear The Roots,
you hear their style.
Or if you hear Radiohead,
For DJ culture, anything goes.
I can take any style and flip it around.
So I'll play you,
because I grew up in the ancient 1990s
when you guys weren't born,
this is a kind of a fun one.
I'll just play you a quick clip.
(uptempo electronic music)
So that's not what,
you guys are getting the art mix.
That's the party mix.
(audience laughing)
Just to clarify there.
That would work for
concerts and parties like this.
You guys are getting a different mix.
You guys are getting to academics mix.
(audience laughing)
(audience chattering)
So that one, you need a big
sound system and a lot of bass.
- [Florian] We're trying to
work with the shopping center
to try to organize it for the fans.
- This is the fun mix.
So I'm giving you guys the
science and stuff like that.
So just so you're aware,
like I said, I inhabit
different ecosystems.
So this probably you got
to have lasers and fog,
maybe you guys would come in the room,
I've got lasers going or something.
- We have some lasers.
(audience laughing)
- Physics is lasers.
All right, so thank you
guys so much for your time
and just it's...
Florian, how do you want it, should we?
- [Florian] If you have any question,
please feel free to do it to ask them.
I'll monitor the chats to make sure
that we have the question
from the audience here.
- Okay.
(audience applauding)
- [Florian] Do you have a question?
- [Audience Member] I was wondering,
when you collect, let's
say weather patterns
and it's got this interesting pattern
and then you transform
into the acoustic domain,
do you have any idea how it's gonna sound
or is that always a surprise?
- You know, there's a couple approaches.
I've worked with the mathematician,
I'll just show you really quickly,
Stephen Wolfram who's probably,
a pretty legendary mathematician.
And just show you.
This is a project where you
can basically compute any style.
And hip-hop, techno, dubstep,
they're usually at four-four
tempo, for example.
Which is relatively trivial to compute.
Then you have minor chord,
usually mostly hip-hop and
techno are minor chords,
et cetera.
So you were able to
actually click on these
and start using it to generate midi
and export the midi
and then pull that into an editing,
Digital Audio Workstation, DAW.
So when I'm working on a project,
I normally don't have
the end result in mind.
The process of making the material,
it depends on the situation.
Like if I'm going for,
you guys are more of like,
I don't view today as a party mix.
So I would probably not
be, but I have other,
that's what I was mentioning earlier,
I have many styles.
I'm using this as an example,
because he was able to
compute almost every aspect
of using an algorithmic approach
to all of the major formats of music.
But for me at least, I'm
very interested in thinking
about existing in multiple ecosystems.
So hip-hop might not
work for certain things
and then house music might
work for other things
and classical music might
work for other things.
And, above all, the notion
of fidelity to the data
is not my foundation.
A lot of people would say you should only,
there are certain other
composers like Ryuichi Akada,
I have a feeling he's not well-known here.
He's a Japanese composer,
he's interesting.
He'll do visual installations
based on a granular synthesis.
And he's very specific about that.
And he projects it large scale,
like small dots and stuff.
He's very Japanese, German minimalism.
That's again, not like a
party or he has very...
I'm using him as an example,
but there's other artists doing sound art.
Usually they avoid beats.
You'll go to a gallery
and there'll be some noise
or some sort of glitchy or
skipping CD sound or something,
but they never have beats.
And so I, on the other hand, go more for,
incorporating beats with the science.
But again, I'm never sure quite
if it's gonna be an exact match,
but it should be a good beginning point.
- [Audience Member]
Yes, we were wondering,
so you were saying that
with quantum computing
and things you were doing here at Yale
it comes with a lot of opportunity
and I was wondering,
because also coming with that,
is it a little responsibility?
What we choose to make
(indistinct) future,
but it seems that this is
a very nice opportunity
to make art and philosophy.
Are you thinking in your project
that you're going be able to incorporate
that sense of responsibility
and kind of ethical questions
about what we work on at all?
- Yeah, I'm fascinated with
entanglement, for example.
And I'm going to use the
idea of quantum entanglement
as a foundation for,
it's part of the residency to look up
and Einstein called it
spooky action at a distance,
for example.
So when you're thinking about the ethics
of being a composer, talking to a sciences
or a composer engaging with
things outside of their normal domain,
you have to imagine that
it's the beginning of a conversation
and how that conversation
goes is the dialectic.
This is just beginning
so the next, I think,
is it 12 or 15 months?
- 12.
- 12 months.
For me, that's millennia.
Normally I do a project in
like a month, it may be,
so I will be coming up to Yale
and also we're going to
host a series of events
in New York as well,
which you guys are all welcome to join.
We will have, you know,
I'll have more firm date for
some of the New York events,
but the idea is the dialectic.
And I'm very intrigued with
how the dialectical process
is at the heart, both of
science and replicate ability.
If you go back to again, the
ancient Greeks doing, you know,
experiments and trying
to figure out things,
I'm inspired by that because
it was like they had,
they were just trying to figure it out.
And it was kind of like, you
know, if you're Archimedes,
you're like I can move the entire world
if I put a lever in the right place.
And okay, how do you calculate that?
And he calculates the entire
circumference of the world.
You know, there's all sorts
of intriguing possibilities,
but the ethics of science
versus the arts is very,
it's a very ambiguous place right now.
One could argue that the
imagination can be weaponized too,
which some people like, for example,
if you're talking about entanglement,
they've already got
some satellites in orbit
using quantum entanglement.
The Chinese launched
satellite a little while ago,
America has launched
a military satellites,
but they're supposed to
be unbreakable encryption
because the entanglement of
all sorts of other processes
that go into that.
Military applications of quantum physics
is definitely a serious issue.
But one also has to
remember if the Americans
aren't doing it, the Israelis are doing,
if not the Israelis then the Chinese,
and it's not the Chinese,
it's the Russians.
And everybody is trying
to figure this stuff out.
And usually it's for some military stuff.
So, as an artist waltzing
through the room, you know,
I don't have machine gun or
extra lasers to fire anybody,
but it's the beginning
of a conversation to me
about how the arts can help make a better
and non-military approach to things.
A lot of this stuff is being
weaponized immediately,
like military funding
for quantum researchers.
It's pretty serious.
I'm not familiar with all the numbers,
but I know it's a very
significant amount of money
being put out a government,
all major governance or their military,
for like artificial
intelligence, quantum computing.
And so, yeah, so.
- [Florian] We have a
question in the chat here,
but they said that something
I experienced is very cool
and I appreciate your
focus on climate change.
They advised to work with
the (indistinct) this year.
And then also they have a question,
how do you connect to a
human or human sounds?
And we thought to integrate
these into your music.
- I'll answer part two first
and then go to this first part.
I wasn't interested in
human sounds in Antarctica.
I was interested in the sounds
more of nature's processes
because everything has rhythm.
Even the absence of a
rhythm is kind of a rhythm.
So the wind, water,
even neutrinos, we took,
I tried to experiment with it,
that was part of an ice cube in Antarctica
that's a neutrino measurement
center where they're looking
at the impact of
neutrinos through the ice.
That was interesting.
Human sounds.
There's a lot of other artists doing that.
So, you know, if you just
Google like sound art,
there's zillions of people doing stuff.
In fact, there's one
actually, who I was working.
I do like Markus Beuhler at MIT.
He's been doing stuff
with the sound of DNA
and he's been doing,
his most infamous piece
was he took the DNA of the COVID virus
and made a series of
electronic music pieces
out of the COVID, you know,
which it sounds like
experimental electronic music,
like no beats or anything.
So the other thing is, yeah,
I would love to work with
y'all's environmental department.
In fact, hopefully we'll reach out to them
over the next couple of months.
- [Florian] Any further
questions from the audience?
If not, let's thank-
(audience applauding)
- I do want to just mention, everybody,
everything I'm talking about,
I'm a big fan of what you
call open source culture.
So much of the work that
I'm doing is open source.
And on my website, there's articles,
there's download material.
There's articles that books,
my books are with MIT.
Lately I've been really interested
in this idea of curating.
I just curated a big
exhibition about Afrofuturism,
which is another art
movement that's pretty cool.
And yeah, I'm a big fan
of the dialect process.
So thank you guys so much for coming out
and I hope to see you guys
over the next couple months.